Speaker 1: There are only so many major news
stories each year, and we have one of them
today.
And this is actually, I would argue, one of
the biggest news stories of the decade.
We've been waiting for the Supreme Court's
decision on abortion rights to cases that
historically establish the right to an abortion
in most cases in the United States.
Those are Roe v Wade and Planned Parenthood.
V Casey, the Supreme Court, we knew sometime
in the next few weeks, maybe by the end of
June, would issue a decision on a mississippi
abortion ban which would in practice overturn
Roe v Wade and Planned Parenthood v Casey.
Depending on what the court decides and that
decision has been leaked, it has not been
announced by the Supreme Court, but it has
been leaked and reputable.
So and if nothing changes, the Supreme Court
will be overturning abortion rights as a federal
in most cases.
Right.
Sending it back to the states, plunging many
states back into.
Should we call it medieval times?
Should we call it the dark ages?
Should we call it the 1850s?
The 1950s?
There are actually two cases here.
Most people know about Roe v Wade, but there's
two cases, Roe v Wade, as well as the 1992
Planned Parenthood decision.
Supreme Court decision.
Planned Parenthood v Casey.
Now, Politico got a copy of the draft opinion.
And this is this is a major scoop.
It really is.
And there are conservatives mad about the
fact that this leaked but obtaining this is
a major scoop and the quote from the majority
opinion believed to be ready to go in a few
weeks is from Supreme Court Justice Samuel
Alito, where he writes, quote, Roe was egregiously
wrong from the start.
Its reasoning was exceptionally weak, and
the decision has had damaging consequences.
And far from bringing about a national settlement
of the abortion issue, Roe and Casey have
inflamed debate and deepened division.
Now, before we go forward with the analysis
on the assumption that this decision isn't
going to change, we should put on record in
case things do change, that sometimes justices
will circulate draft opinions and there's
still revisions and changes and sometimes
horse trading for votes.
I mean, things happen.
You would think that that doesn't happen at
the Supreme Court, but it does.
And up until days before it's made official.
Opinions can change, but right now, Roe v
Wade goes bye bye.
Planned Parenthood v Casey goes Bye bye now.
On the issue of blame, because I've gotten
a ton of messages from people about who do
we blame here?
Do we blame the people that didn't vote for
Hillary and all this different stuff?
Listen, we most it's like when there is a
bill, I'm not even going to make any analogies.
We mostly blame the Supreme Court justices
who voted this way.
Okay.
But we primarily blame them.
And when it comes to the Supreme Court, then
you go, well, why are they there?
And so you go to Trump.
We Trump's choices are what made this a plausible
reality.
And we predicted and we were worried that
it would happen and it looks like it's happening.
So we blame the justices and we blame the
president who put them there?
Who's Donald Trump?
Well, why was Trump there?
We mostly blame the people who voted for Donald
Trump and put him in this position.
But we also say, hey, as an instructive element,
as something we should remember, those people
who said, Hillary, Trump, it's all the same.
It's all the same.
I'm going to stay home or I'm going to write
in whoever because they said Supreme Court,
I don't care about the Supreme Court when
I was here saying, you realize what could
happen if Trump wins and gets to pick Supreme
Court justices.
Right.
And some of you said, oh, I don't care about
that.
That's not a big deal.
Well, there is some responsibility there as
well.
But most of it is the people who voted for
Trump and Trump and the Supreme Court justices
that he put there.
We don't have to go crazy fighting about it.
We just have to remember in case this comes
up again, if you didn't vote for Hillary in
2016, this was the risk you assumed.
I'm not saying you're a bad person, but this
was the risk you assumed you thought it was
worth.
I don't know.
Sending a message to the DNC or whatever.
And that's totally fine.
That's your right.
But this was the rescue assumed and now this
is where we are now.
The one thing here that could be a silver
lining.
I've been saying Democrats are heading towards
a disastrous and potentially historic defeat
in the midterms in November.
It's possible possible that this might be
what lights a fire under the left to say,
wow, now we see the repercussions.
We've got to get out there and vote.
I'll come.
Back to that.
Let's go back a little bit.
You know, we often talk about how all Supreme
Court nominees play coy when asked about abortion,
and they say, well, it might come before the
court.
And I can't prejudge in all these different
things.
Just as a reminder, here's Samuel Alito back
at his confirmation hearing in 2006, kind
of dancing around the question of is abortion
constitutionally protected?
He said it was not in an earlier writing before
being nominated.
Here's how he danced around this question
during his confirmation hearings.
Speaker 2: Specter then brought up the often
cited letter Alito wrote in 1985 and applying
for a job in the Reagan White House stating
The Constitution does not protect our right
to an abortion.
Do you agree with that statement today?
Judge Alito Well, that was a correct statement
of what I thought in 1985 from my vantage
point in 1985.
And that was as a line attorney in the Department
of Justice in the Reagan administration.
Today, if the issue were to come before me,
if I am fortunate enough to be confirmed and
the issue were to come before me, then I would
have to that I would approach the question
with an open mind.
And I would I would listen to you.
I would approach with an open mind, notwithstanding
your 1985 statement.
Absolutely, Senator.
That was a statement that I made at a prior
period of time when I was performing a different
role.
And as I said yesterday, when when someone
becomes a judge, you really have to put aside
the things that you did as a lawyer, you know,
at prior points in your legal career.
And think about legal issues the way a judge
thinks about legal issues.
Speaker 1: Here are Trump's three Supreme
Court nominees Amy Coney Barrett, Brett Kavanaugh
and Neil Gorsuch.
When Roe v Wade and abortion precedent came
up during their confirmation hearings.
Speaker 3: Is Roe a super precedent?
Speaker 4: How would you define super precedent?
I'm answering a lot of questions about Roe,
which I think indicates that Roe doesn't fall
in that category.
And scholars across the spectrum say that
doesn't mean that Roe should be overruled,
but descriptively, it does mean that it's
not a case that everyone has accepted and
doesn't call for its overruling.
Speaker 2: As a judge.
It is an important precedent of the Supreme
Court.
By it I mean Roe v Wade and Planned Parenthood
versus Casey then reaffirmed many times, Casey
is precedent on precedent, which itself is
an important factor.
Senator, as the book explains, the Supreme
Court of the United States as held in Roe
versus Wade, that a fetus is not a person
for purposes of the 14th Amendment.
And the book explains that.
Do you accept that that's the law of the land?
I accept the law of the land, Senator.
Yes.
Speaker 1: So everybody just kind of playing
it off like, I don't know.
You know, there's precedent.
It's the law.
I don't have any big desire to overturn Roe
v Wade.
But now, if nothing changes, it will be gone.
Go back to what Hillary Clinton said back
in 2018, where she said, quote, If Brett Kavanaugh
becomes a Supreme Court justice, will he help
gut or overturn Roe v Wade, which legalized
abortion in America?
Yes, of course he will.
And she was right.
And I am no fan of Hillary, but Hillary was
right about many things, it turns out, in
retrospect.
This makes Donald Trump an extraordinarily
consequential.
President Trump, as far as we know personally,
isn't even pro-life.
Trump was vocally pro-choice until he was
68 years old, and then he ran as a Republican
and had to come up with this explanation.
Well, I met a kid I liked, and the mom said
at one point she thought about aborting.
And so then I was pro-life.
Nobody believes that if you're thinking critically.
But it doesn't change that.
Trump may now be the most consequential anti-abortion
president in history at this point in time,
a totally clueless doofus.
But he figured out a way to overturn Roe v
Wade, something I don't think he even cares
about personally.
This lets each state decide, do we restrict
abortion?
Do we ban abortion?
And I've said it isn't even really clear what
Democrats could do to save the midterms.
But this reality that states now could ban
or restrict abortion in absolutely authoritarian,
retrograde ways.
Maybe it will help Democrats not get crushed
in November.
We talked about what if Biden forgives some
student loan debt?
What about cannabis decriminalization?
I don't know.
This could be the thing.
It is possible that this is exactly the earth
shattering wake up call that might get people
to go out and vote because they realize this
is Dark Ages stuff.
We're leaving the country to retrograde elements
of society to run things, and this issue could
potentially reshape the midterms.
And we'll talk about that.
More protests are already surging.
Police are setting up barriers at the Supreme
Court and this could inspire all sorts of
new voters, apathetic voters.
We just can't say yet.
Now, what do people do in red states?
Does everyone with common sense leave the
red states to go to the safe haven of blue
states?
I don't know.
Do the leftists flood the red states to make
them no longer red?
And it is really quite the situation.
And, you know, for us who live in blue states
like New York, much will probably not change.
That's a reality.
But for many people in other parts of the
country, it will be a disaster.
Now, what's next?
What's next?
Because some of the people against abortion.
Are also against interracial marriage.
Some of them are against divorce for religious
reasons, or at least claimed to be.
Some of them are against gay adoption.
Some of them are against gay marriage.
They want it to be legal to fire people for
their gender identity or sexual orientation,
which, by the way, is still legal in more
than 20 states.
They want to be able to whatever.
And once they discover that you can take away
established rights from people, if you put
the right people on the court and do the right
things at the state level to get a case in
front of the Supreme Court.
Why would they stop here?
They're not going to.
That is for damn sure.
So we are going backwards.
And next, I want to talk a little bit about
the reaction from MAGA World to what we have
learned overnight.